Dave Chappelle stormed off stage in
Florida last weekend after catching a
member of the audience secretly
recording his show by now most people
know that when you go see Chappelle live
it's required to lock your phone in one
of these bags from the moment you enter
till the moment you leave restricting
phone access not only makes for a more
engaged audience and a better overall
show but it also allows these bigname
comedians a chance to take comedic risks
and work out new jokes without the fear
of someone taking their set out of
context or spoiling a punchline by
leaking jokes on the internet so when he
caught someone in the stands filming day
two of his five night stint in Miami it
makes sense that